[Musique]
il
alors monsieur rastaquouère hausse
bonjour merci d'un jour
où nouveau délit days plus sérieusement
merci d'être ici on est à versailles on
est ici à l'occasion de l'avant première
de votre dernier film qui s'intitule
bécassine vous êtes dans votre ville
natale ce qui nous vaut la joie de vous
interviewez tous ayant mais oui je suis
content est au cirano c'est un cinéma
que j'aime énormément c'est là où
j'allais
j'ai vu mes premiers films oui
c'est là où j'ai vu mary poppins qui m'a
beaucoup inspiré pour bécassine ouais
bah on va y venir justement donc
bécassine quelle drôle d'idée si je peux
me permettre comment est venue des bas
c'est une idée de rôle non seulement une
drôle d'idée mais une idée drôle lorsque
bécassine est là
elle a quelque chose de
je trouve d'ajustement
on lui reproche beaucoup de choses a
cédé cassine alors que c'est une jeune
femme de papier très attachante j'ai
appris à la découvrir
en écrivant le film et je
fois drôle et émouvante c'est un beau
cocktail ouest et alors est ce qu elle
faisait partie de votre imaginaire
enfantin c'est un peu jeune pour ça tout
de même nom oui en fait ce bécassine
choix pour beaucoup de gens c'est à fait
partie du paysage il ya toujours un
album qui traîne qui maison ils sont
beaux voilà on est en campagne on
feuillette donc c'est les gens qui sont
familiers que la figure de la bonne
bouille de bécassine
les mecs par contre connaissent mal son
geste à caractère l'histoire aussi oui
alors comment vous y êtes pris pour
construire cette histoire parce que si
le soir complètement original je crois
c'est un scénario vous avez écrit voilà
comment vous avez fait et bien j'ai
humblement
découvert bon nombre d'albums et puis
j'ai prélevé des ingrédients à droite à
gauche pour que les gens qui aiment
bécassine s'y retrouve et puis bien les
choses un peu récurrente des albums des
parties ses fondamentaux comme on dit
aujourd'hui oui enfin quelques noms de
personnages monsieur proéminent la
marquise de grand air
lou lot j'ai gardé comme ça quelques
quelques personnages et puis quelques
petits gags parfois aussi qu'il n'y ait
que je trouvais encore drôle et
et j'ai écrit une histoire qui
correspondait plus à moi mes envies si
j'avais envie de faire un film pour les
enfants surtout
comment je les capterait comment
qu'est-ce que je le rencontrais je suis
parti dans cet esprit là d'accord pour
plaire à pas pour l'heure surtout en
pensant aux enfants même si j'espère que
les grands s'ennuieront pas mais j'ai
pensé vraiment à toucher les enfants
dans leurs chais pas
bécassine et l'attachante parce que
c'est vraiment une grande personne mais
qui résonne toujours qui réagit comme un
enfant bon je sens que les enfants va
être intrigué par cette
grande dame si proche d'eux d'accord et
en plus enfin moi ce que je trouve c'est
que c'est avant tout la grande amie la
nourrissent presque la maman de
substitution cette fameuse lolotte oui
et c'est surtout très belle histoire
entre elles d'un oui oui c'est nous et
même si c'était pas prévu nos sens
l'itinéraire du tout non
être contents de rencontrer ses petites
filles avec qui elle noue une relation
qui est particulière parce que c'est pas
sa mère c'est pas sa soeur s'est pas
s'attendre c'est pas sa copine c'est
peut-être sa marraine justement comme
mary poppins ouais mais justement on
peut faire le parallèle avec une mary
poppins on peut dire que bécassine et la
mary poppins française mais bienveillant
d'une compréhension des enfants du jazz
initiative
whi à ceci près que la magie de
bécassine c'est dans ces inventions elle
ce n'est pas des pouvoirs magiques
surnaturel comme avait travaillé son
ciboulot way son très bon à ce que
d'autres peuvent penser les rased est
déjà tout le monde et oui parce que
souvent je trouve que les gens gentils
montre ainsi un signe extérieur
d'intelligence web et donc ça la magie
de bécassine c'est d'être cédé mais en
fait oui en plus elle a des inventions
complètement enfin très ingénieuse dans
le film alors est ce que c'est vous qui
les avait inventés ou est-ce qu'elles
sont dans les albums comment ça s'est
passé elle invente par exemple un
biberon qui se donnent au mettre
automatiquement parce qu'elle est un peu
fatigués la nuit un électeur 9 à la coke
dans le biberon par exemple c'est un
dessin c'est un schéma qu'elle a fait
dans les albums que j'ai filmé tel quel
qui a un contrat aussi mais en fait est
bon et dans les albums je pêche
quoiqu'elle ne construit pas mais nous
au cinéma s'y met on a les moyens donc
on a construit ce binôme systématique et
il fonctionne merveilleusement les
écarts d'être à l'école non ça c'est ça
tu sais pas trop c'est un oui si
d'accord et alors comment on s'est émue
mme bayard qui joue bécassine après on
retrouve karine viard en madame de
grands airs un petit peu rajeuni
d'ailleurs oui vous l'osez d'accord elle
est un peu vieilli ostermann ap de grand
air dans les albums là vous l'avez
choisi un petit peu plus pimpante oui je
vais m
conçoit que le château soit gay quoi que
ce soit pas austère oui austère ou
finissant tout comme la fortune comme ça
se dilapide au moins
la gaieté toujours là entre les gens du
château est d'accord alors comment vous
allez penser à cette emeline bayart
cette actrice pour le rôle eh bien j'ai
pas été la chercher en fait j'ai
travaillé déjà deux fois avec elle dans
d'autres les films géniaux film davant
et nagui
voilà adieu berthe et puis
public oui ton à versailles est
en fait j'avais vu que cette actrice
était extraordinaire et méconnus comme
un peu comme agassi et du coup j'ai
superposant les visages des mines et
dessins de bécassine j'ai vu un film
possible
j'ai écrit en pensant l est est ce que
c'est un peu délicate proposer ce
personnage mais nos rédactrices pas et
c'est ce qu'on peut croire ou ajuster
oui mais en fait moi déjà j'avais une
image positive de bécassine je voyais
pas communiquer nos rituels et émis par
chance avait la même
la même image c'est pas du tout senti
ça
froisse et qu'on lui propose bkc parce
qu'elle avait contrait une vision assez
idéalisée de cette femme aimante
intrépide
vaillante elle avait l'air très positif
sur le personnage
d'accord et je sais pas si vous avez
j'imagine que vous savez françoise dolto
on a dit beaucoup de bien aux justement
sur ces ses méthodes pédagogiques elle
parle d'une pédagogie bienveillante
d'une écoute d'une modernité finalement
dans sa passion de s'occuper cette
petite culotte oui oui mais je comprends
bien parce que comme je disais comme
c'est ni la mère ni la copie ni la soeur
elle crée une relation presque d'égal à
égal avec l'enfant oui mais pour
l'époque c'est un peu moderne c'était
très moderne je pensais que c'était
moderne il n'y a jamais de punition au
sens
résultat de l'époque serre que vraiment
on la voit jamais levé la main sur un
enfant
procuré beaucoup de douceur et de
patience
d'accord moi je trouvais je sais pas ce
que vous allez en pensez mais je
trouvais qu'il y avait une sorte de
ressemblance entre le personnage de
comme un avion que vous jouez qui rament
oui et bécassine c'est à dire c'est le
sont deux personnages qui partent en
voyage épique finalement ça a très vite
eu éthique qui pour des raisons
affectives reste la boisson oui mais non
comme un avion il faisait de rentrer
mais elle elle reste et c'est rigolo ce
espèce de notion de voyage que ça aille
vite
non non c'est vrai c'est un volontaire
de ma part mais même les affiches le
personnage principal et dont il a un
projet et la raison du bonheur c'est
qu'ils abandonnent ce projet pour
l'instant pour vivre le présent
l'affectif pour l'affairé de rencontre
mais la rencontre ouais et du coup je me
demandais comment vous vous attribuez
les rôles dans vos filles parce que vous
jouez dans chacun de vos filles dans des
décors alors celui ci comment vous êtes
dit parce que vous l'avez inventé ce
personnage est de art vous êtes monsieur
rastaquouère rose comme j'ai commencé
tout à l'heure c'est un grec oui
d'ailleurs vous êtes d'origine grecque
au daily mail et vous êtes
marionnettiste ses seins et à comment
vous avez comment vous vous dites qu'est
ce que je vais faire dans le film
commence at elle décida je me demande au
dernier moment puisque je fais pas dit
non tu vas dormir et je me donne pas du
tout de neuro j'écris pas pour moi ce
qui fait que du coup je si c'était pour
moi peut-être je serai moins bien servis
parce que là je donne je me suis donné
le bon rôle
dans le film
et j'ai pensé à plusieurs acteurs
formidables d'ailleurs donc vous aviez
déjà ce personnage de marionnettistes on
est d'accord le personnage oui mais si
on veut dire que moi je jouerai est
d'ailleurs à paris mines j'évoque un
acteur en tête pour le film et après je
je distribue les cartes comme ça je fais
des permutations
et parce que j'essaye de trouver des
personnages qu'ils soient pas toujours
exactement idée formidable pour le rôle
pour payer pour notre addiction voilà on
les attend forcément très exactement
quand on va soit trop cliché donc gg
pour saccharine parents se trouve
qu'elle est bien ce qu'elle nous donne
une marquise
la conventionnelle quoi le 13 et
l'inattendu oui pour thesis tu
rigoles est bon et du coup vous êtes
débat tient ce rôle est pour moi pour en
revenir à ma question oui oui parce que
à un moment j j'ai tellement jour
marionnettes et confrère denis
j'ai tellement familier de de cet
univers
de saltimbanques comme ça talent quand
je dis femmes initiative a toujours fait
rêver c'est petit spectacle travers sa
campagne pour dresser leurs petits
chapiteaux sont les petites et les
cogner ça enfin en tant que spectateurs
oui bien sûr
ah oui le guignol de campagne
versailles à la personne
et du coup vous êtes dit ce roulé pour
moi oui j'allais faire oui bah oui parce
qu'un petit côté arsène lupin
petit côté puis vous avez un goût pour
la magie c'est pas de la magie là j'en
fais pas vraiment mais je manipule un
peu quand même mais c'est toujours voilà
on est un petit peu margoulins mais
alors ces personnages il est positif il
est plus positif évidemment puisqu'il
apporte de la fantaisie la gaieté de
lier way de l'air frais c'est grossier
il est un petit peu pas très honnête non
il s'est même vous savez on disait un
grec avant ça voulait dire tricheurs
donc
ça m'amuse tous les enfants sont
troublés il aime bien savoir qui sont
les gentils et méchants qui sont les
méchants riz est là avec ce personnage
qui s'appelle je ne sais pas mais c'est
ça qui vient j'aimerais que ce soit
comme dans la vie
et blanc ou noir il a des bons côtés
puis d'autres un peu plus trouble oui
c'est ça et puis finalement on va pas
dévoiler la fin de l'histoire enfin des
questions elle sort à ses triomphes en
deux de l'histoire est là bas de chasse
on s'aimait cassine ce sera les
classiques qui se termine mal mais jeudi
elle fait preuve d'un peu de génie tout
ça lui est alors donc on retrouve un
petit peu votre noyau habituel d'act up
denis podalydès évidemment monsieur
proéminent on a vu mal à fonds sont
nationaux elle goûtait qui était un
versailles a d'ailleurs qu'est-ce qui
est d'autres bals musette et mermoz ou
si les gens ont fait jouer régulièrement
oui oui tout à fait art choix c'est un
pratique vous est donné par choix parce
qu'ils sont sûrs les acteur formidable
dopeur que je m'en priverais et ouais
vraiment oui donc voilà et après vous
êtes c'est la première fois que vous
donnez un rôle féminin
un premier rôle c'est pas très clair ma
phrase c'est la première fois que je
rêvais d'avoir un premier rôle féminin
se méfie mais grâce à ces bécassine et
bien c'est le cas
j'espère pas alors vous êtes allé en
bretagne en avant-première quel est
l'accueil les bretons étaient ravis de
voir le film
c'était vraiment très touché parce que
ils ont surmonté leur leurs a priori sur
le
oui oui oui bien sûr on est breton a
beaucoup beaucoup de gens
en a priori négatif sur bécassine
permettent un physio difficile à sortir
pour ça parce qu'il fait les gens
surmontent
un truc pas très
claire sur certains sites bien passé
1905 oui mais l'arrestation a oui ça
paraît quand même fou non non c'est vrai
je trouve ça amusant mais j'aime bien au
cinéma quand j'ai un préjugé qui tombe
je vous ai dit si les gens sur moncla
dans cette voie là ça sera encore moins
comme bon bah c'est le cas je crois oui
finalement vous la fait ressusciter
voulu donner un regard vous portez un
regard différent sur elle et vous la
donner un petit coup de jeune et de
peps et d'intelligence on l'a on la voit
comme elle est vraiment finalement oui
10 gt barton film à reculons et et
j'aurais qui viennent le voir en marche
avant oui je suis sorti à reculons parce
que je voulais y retourner non mais
écoutez bravo merci pour ce joli film on
peut dire c'est une comédie poétique
une bougie le terme
non j'ai pris un terme générique j est
une comédie
sensible
pour votre votre façon évidemment et
puis pour tout le monde parce que j'ai
vu des enfants en très bas âge qui ont
suivi une
filière j'ai présenté film à chatou et
d'un petit garçon l'a pris le micro pour
dire ses plus beaux films de sa vie ah
mon dieu si je n'attends que ça m'a
touché j'imagine moi j'ai vu avec un
petit garçon de 10 ans qui a adoré ça
super moyens voilà hockey m'a écouté un
grand mât si le prochain film on sait
déjà ce que ça va être non je sais pas
encore mais maintenant j'ai deux
passions de femelles 2 ouais on attend
deux ans j'espère moi aussi j'espère
merci vous no mercy alpha bien sûr
d'accord merci et bravo pour ce beau
sinon merci
je